(upbeat music)
- Welcome to "The Think Marketing Show."
The number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest moneymaking strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel,
or maximized online video
across social media,
this is for you.
We're talking all about
scripting videos today.
So what are some of your
tips for making good videos?
- Yeah, so I think that this is a big deal
because if you fail to
plan, you plan to fail.
However, there's also a
tension that we live in
where we can be in analysis paralysis
or we can just be planning forever.
And let us know maybe in the comments
if you're on either of those two extremes
where you just kind of wing it
and the content's not that great
or you're so stuck and you're like,
"I need to make it more perfect,
to plan the notes more."
I think there's kind of a happy middle
and that's what we try to do kind of,
in our process here at Think Media.
And so, I have a few tips I wrote down.
I think the first one is
to always reverse-engineer.
You gotta start with the end in mind.
Like, what is even the
point of this YouTube video?
Is the point of the video
actually just to experiment?
Are you just trying to
kind of figure out YouTube,
get comfortable on camera?
Then why are you even overthinking it?
Just grab your phone, hit
record and start shooting.
Is the point of the video to educate
people about your business?
Do you at the end of the video want them
to go to your website, or call you,
or fill out an application form
to hire you as a real estate agent,
or apply for a loan, or something?
Like, what do you want the video to do?
Is the point of the video
to just grow your influence period?
Add free value to the marketplace.
What is the point of the video?
And a lot of times we don't
start it with the end in mind.
We just start recording and then we go,
"But how should we position this?"
Or, "What is the purpose of this video?"
Have you noticed this?
- Yeah definitely, I think even
in my own content creation,
I sometimes skip this
step and then it makes
putting the video out even harder.
If you don't already just
know where is this going,
who is this for, what type
of content am I putting
in this video, and why
am I making this video,
it makes it so much harder at the end.
So I think that reverse-engineering,
like you're saying,
is so critical and as a new creator,
it was one of the things
I struggled with the most
because not only was it hard to get
comfortable in front of the camera,
and gain confidence to turn the camera on,
but then to think I need to
know where this is going,
and what this is for, and who this is for,
that's a lot of complexity
in video creation.
And so, this piece to me has
been one of the biggest growth
that I've had in creating videos.
And I think this right here
is one of the biggest pieces
that you teach in all of video creation.
- Yeah totally, and our friend Peter
actually says it this way, he says,
"Think things through,
then follow through."
And we're so busy in today's culture,
and we're on our phones,
and we feel frantic to create a video.
Like, slow down, plan on paper.
And really just brainstorm some ideas
and answer some of those questions.
Okay, what do I really wanna do with this?
How do I wanna show up for the video?
What do I want people to
experience in this video?
What would winning look like?
Like, if this video really did awesome,
what would it accomplish?
Would it get a lot of views?
Would it get a lot of subscribers?
What it get people to sign
up for a free giveaway?
Would it get people to
register for a conference?
Would it just build general aware?
Like really just, and
that takes some time.
Even if it's 10 or 15 minutes
looking at that paper,
but then number two is then research
before you press record.
And this is the idea that especially
because YouTube is a search engine,
now that you've hopefully
planned on paper,
you have a general idea of I kinda know
what I wanna talk about.
I know what my target audience,
the people I'm trying to reach,
are looking for generally.
I know what this video is
gonna be generally like.
You want to then actually research,
do some keyword research.
And so, some of our
favorite tools right now are
we use the vidIQ keyword planner.
That one is on the other side
of the Boost program for vidIQ
and we actually have an
affiliate relationship with them,
and we love using them.
That's like VidIQ.com/think,
but there's also free ones.
Ubersuggest right now is a
good keyword research tool,
that's totally free.
And we'll link to a couple of others
in the description below.
We go deeper in this of
course in other videos.
And so, we also have a playlist.
We'll link that up and put
that in the description,
on specifically our process
for how to research,
how to come up with those video ideas,
but here's the 101 of it.
Take what you've done on
your planning on paper stage
to the YouTube search bar.
Have you ever gone to
the YouTube search bar,
well I know you have, but
we're like laying this out,
so play with me.
So, you go to the YouTube search bar,
you start typing, what happens?
- It starts predicting other words
beyond the word that I typed in.
- Absolutely, people
have seen that on Google.
It finishes your sentence
for you, it's autocomplete.
And so, if you go to then
the YouTube search bar,
you can start typing...
You know that in reverse-engineer stage,
you're like okay, "What
I wanna talk about is
"I know I've got a cooking channel
"and I wanna talk about how
to cook steak in a frying pan,
"which is gonna be
different than baking it,
"different than a grill."
So you start typing, "How to cook steak."
Well that's too broad and
you actually will see,
and people can test this at home,
it'll finish your sentence for you.
It'll be like, "How to
cook steak on a grill.
"How to cook steak in a frying pan.
"How to cook steak in an oven.
"How to cook steak, how to boil steak."
It'll start maybe switching it.
That is then what would be
101 of the research phase.
And what YouTube is telling you there,
is it's telling you the
exact keyword phrases
that people are searching.
Like what they're typing
into YouTube in order.
So then there's a list of 'em,
the top one is the most
searched on YouTube,
the bottom one is the least searched.
And this is like now, it's
giving you so much clarity
'cause it's basically telling you,
"Okay, this is the way I should
"now position what I've planned.
"This is what will be
probably influencing my title.
"This will influence the
whole rest of the process."
And here's the thing.
Most people miss these first two steps
and therefore their
results suffer on YouTube.
- Yeah, and I think you're so right.
It's like, even before you
get to scripting a video,
there's actually steps that happen before
that are so critical to
make sure that the video
that you're putting the
time, and the effort,
and the energy into
actually produce something.
- 100%.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference
"Grow With Video Live," a $1,500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe
and leave us a review on Apple Podcasts.
And then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- So then we've now defined
the keywords that we want.
Then number three is really interesting
because I thought when I
first started creating videos
that this next step was towards the end
after you made the video, but it's not.
What's number three?
- So then number three is I actually think
you should plan out your title next.
And so, you haven't even
outlined your video.
You may be have some rough ideas on paper.
You have some keyword research,
so maybe now you know
that your video is about
how to prepare your 2020 taxes,
or how to new 2020 tax laws
if you're an accountant.
This applies for any industry.
People are searching for
specific things in any industry.
How to, it could be marketing.
How to build a sales funnel.
Or how to fix a WordPress...
Like a million things.
Best settings for the Canon M50,
like those are types of videos we do.
So you kinda have the keywords,
but now you wanna actually
figure out the title
meaning how's it gonna be...
Now you don't have to make it perfect yet.
But this again, is
gonna set the North Star
for the entire video.
Sometimes what you'll learn
here is that you also might be
sitting on more than one video.
What you prepared on paper
actually is gonna make
a great four videos instead of just one.
We've learned that sometimes
we can break down tech training,
tech education into
multiple different pieces.
It's like people need to learn how to set
the auto focus settings
best for a certain camera,
but then it's also how do you
get the audio settings right,
but then how do you get the color right?
And sure, all of those could go
under a big video like 10 tips.
They also could potentially be
broken down into different videos.
So in this process, those
are some of the conclusions
you can make and here's
why this is so powerful.
You haven't taken a shower and
picked out your clothes yet.
You haven't put makeup
on or set up lights.
You haven't made sure your
batteries are charged.
You haven't spent a lot of energy
doing the hard work of creating content.
You're actually spending a lot of energy
doing the hard work of
planning your content,
but it's gonna save you so
much energy in the long run.
When we sit down at Think,
just our company overall,
and start planning content,
a lot of times we'll start
seeing it splinter off and we'll be like,
"Okay, because we're planning on paper,"
and by the way, we use Google Docs,
so we'll plan digitally but we like
to keep everything in Google Docs.
If you wanna collab with other people,
you can add them really easy
and everyone can type in there together.
And so, we then began seeing,
"Okay, this could also turn into this,"
and I've learned I prefer
to do this the day before.
I always prefer not to plan
or to prepare any videos
the same day I'm gonna shoot the videos.
It's almost like two
different types of the brain
where you're more in planning mode.
You've got your coffee,
you've got your Google Docs.
You're getting it all
dialed in and organized.
So then, and then you come
in with a level of structure,
where you're like, actually,
it's gonna be video number
one, video number two.
It's gonna have roughly of this title,
roughly video number two
is gonna have this title.
I wanna hit these general
points which brings us
kind of into the next point.
- Yeah, and the next point is something
where I think that as you're
walking through your videos,
there are different types of videos.
So if you're doing an
interview-style video,
or if you are doing maybe a
sales video at the teleprompter.
But we wanna get into
the content, the meat,
the piece that is really important.
So now we have our title.
How do you plan your content?
How do you know what goes into the video?
- Yeah so, tip number four is
then to outline your video.
Now we're sittin' here doin'
the "Think Marketing Show,"
and I this morning
actually, breaking my rules,
but it's crazy as shoot week here and so,
we've been packin' a lot of stuff in.
So I did block the time and
made sure I went to bed early.
And I wanted to be super hydrated.
I knew we had a big shoot day.
And so, I opened up Google Docs.
You looked at all the topics.
- Yeah, I did topics and
I got some idea of titles
based on where we want this show to go.
- Absolutely, so then I ran with those,
and I started to bullet point
points underneath those.
So I would say for me,
the outline the video is bullet points
and I also like to have numbers, you know?
It brings some organization to it.
We've got five points here
so people can follow along hopefully.
And not just have just
general flowing information,
what did I walk away with,
but something concrete.
This would definitely be
more relevant for education,
how to, training, when
you're teaching something,
when you're helping somebody get a result
moving from point A to point B to point C.
And then I've also learned though,
that during this phase
you wanna give yourself
a little bit of margin
to bullet a few points,
but then also to do further research.
So for me this means verifying
and studying out my ideas.
So what we've learned,
especially with doing 100s
of videos on Think Media,
is I'm like, okay, if I was gonna
tell somebody how to use the best,
how to setup their camera to shoot video,
I'd probably tell 'em to do X, Y, and Z,
and there's like three points.
Then what I like to do is maybe watch
what are other people teaching on this?
I'll read a few blogs about it.
I'll actually then say,
"You know, what you wanna do
"is make sure your frame rate
is set to 60 frames a second."
And then I like to challenge
myself, "Is that true?"
And then I like to go to blogs and forums.
I actually really, again,
you haven't pressed
record on the video yet,
so you haven't actually, you don't wanna,
it's very hard to go back
and change the video later.
You have to re-shoot it if
you said something wrong.
So I like to verify and study my ideas
as much as possible on paper
staring at the computer.
And then, that way I go, "Oh wow."
And sometimes I'll catch a
nugget from somebody else's video
where they'll say, "Yeah, I
tried that and it didn't work."
Or, "Did you know?"
And I'll be like, "Oh yeah,
that makes perfect sense."
And it'll just tweak one of my ideas
and take it to just kind of another level.
It's giving the content
some time to breathe
and if possible, where this
becomes really powerful
is if you do space this out even more.
I found that once you've
planned for a while,
prepared for a while,
and then taking a break.
Go on a run, go on a jog,
take a break, take a nap,
like get just out of your normal element.
I don't know if people are like me,
tell me if you're like
this in the comments.
If you're then, if you're
doin' something else.
You're driving with your
kids and all of a sudden
an idea pops into your
head and you're like,
"Wait a minute, I totally
forgot a whole point."
Have you ever noticed that happen?
- Yeah.
- You let your prepared content breathe
and it actually makes it stronger
and you haven't even pressed record yet.
- Yeah, it's so critical that
these steps that we're doing
before we even press record,
it makes shoot days so much easier.
I know we found here at Think Media
that if we aren't planned,
we will miss entire shoot days
because we end up planning
these types of things.
And one of the things I
love that you've taught me
is that once you start making
those lists, like five things,
you challenge yourself to say,
"Well are there seven
steps versus five steps?"
And really thinking
about are you putting out
the best content and
are you actually sharing
everything for that person to
get from point A to point B?
So the next is the final notes.
What is that like?
- Yeah, so now, think about this.
We've gone through, we've
reverse-engineered the big idea.
We've researched before we pressed record.
We kinda know some keyword
research that we've done.
We've planned out the general title.
We've outlined the video.
And now we're looking at it saying, "Okay,
"what is it missing and what
else would make it stronger?"
These are things like should
there be any calls-to-action?
And this is sort of a deeper
concept we teach in some
of our training programs called
like Circular Video Viralocity.
If possible, in the middle of the video,
if you teach a point, do you
teach that somewhere else,
in another one of your videos?
You could link to that, and
that's then being able to say,
just like we kind of did in this video,
"If you wanna learn more about research
"before you press record,
click or tap the YouTube card,
"or click the link in
the description below."
If I have, I had this written in my notes.
That's a call-to-action that
happened during the last phase
of okay, that's a final note.
Where could I weave in
some things like that?
Are there any props that we need?
We're shooting a batch of
the "Think Media Show" today,
and so I brought like
seven different shirts
just so I could go through
the different shirts
for the shoot, and so, make
sure I have those prepared.
Are there people that we need?
Do we need any help with this?
Or it's like, "Hey man, can you
be there to help me set up?"
or and even if you're doin'
this solo you're like,
"Hey honey, can you make sure
the kids aren't in the house."
Like, looking ahead, what
else, is there any final notes
and getting that all on paper.
Again, if you fail to
plan, you plan to fail.
This is that strategic...
One of our favorite quotes is Sun Tzu,
author of "The Art of War,"
a famous military general.
"Every battle is won
before it's even fought."
And I think that's why a lot
of entrepreneurs are losing
and a lot of people, content
creators, are losing,
is because they're so frantic right now.
They haven't taken the time to slow down
and really strategize,
to slow down and really
think things through,
and then follow through.
If every battle is won
before it's ever fought,
that means we're planning on paper.
It means that you're
standing over the battlefield
with the miniature
characters and thinkin',
"Okay, am I thinkin' all this through?
"Do we have the gear we
need, the notes we need?"
And things can happen because this is
stuff that gets us tripped up.
Once you even think that
this could be notes about,
"What gear do I need, what outfit?
"Do I need to charge the batteries?
"Do I need to make sure
that, oh shoot, that's right.
"My camera is at my sister's house.
"I'm not even gonna be
able to shoot tomorrow."
This stuff happens all the time
and we've noticed that it'll
just trip your shoot up.
You're like, "Tomorrow I'm gonna
get like five videos done."
I don't know, like give
me an amen in the comments
if you're like, "Completely."
I thought Saturday morning was gonna be
this really effective
thing, and then I was like,
"Oh that's right, I
didn't plug my camera in
"and I have to wait hours to charge
"the battery for my camera."
All those little types of deal.
I know this could kinda
sound overwhelming,
but it's actually by investing in energy
in scripting your videos, and
planning them ahead of time,
that it saves you massive
energy in the future.
- Yeah, are there any
parts of videos that you
do like to actually
script out word for word?
What are the key elements
in a video that you think
need to be in it when people
are actually at the phase
of getting those video scripts done?
- In my opinion, I think
the most important part of,
so for me, I'm good with an outline
and just bullet pointing the points.
And that'll keep me on track,
maybe adding in some call-to-actions,
any other notes that need to
be added under each point,
or a disclaimer, or a
by-the-way, you know?
But the hook, the intro,
the first 10 seconds,
it could be 30 seconds,
it could even be a minute,
I believe should almost potentially
be scripted word-for-word.
Especially if you're
newer to YouTube videos
and to marketing and
grabbing people's attention
because they will, people will forgive you
and watch the rest of the video
if you've set it up right.
But if you mess up those first few seconds
and you don't create some curiosity,
if you don't hook people's attention
making them wanna watch more.
If you don't actually set the stage
for what they're about to learn
and they're not even
interested in learning more.
If you don't maybe say
there's five points coming up,
or have any kind of nuggets,
you wanna think through
all those types of things.
And that's probably a topic
for a whole nother episode
of the "Think Media Show" some day.
But yeah, I will oftentimes
write a sentence or two or three
and I'll try to nail
that hook in that intro,
and then after that, I
kinda relax a little bit,
and then just try to
hit the bullet points.
But that's some precious time.
And with everybody scrolling
through the different
social media platforms, you
only have a few seconds.
There's actually the goldfish rule
that they did a study,
Microsoft did a study,
that goldfish have an attention
span of eight seconds.
But humans now, because of
social media and phones,
our attention span is seven seconds.
So Heather, you've got the
attention span of a goldfish.
- I know, I feel it.
(laughing)
- You do, as do I, you know what I mean?
And so, that means that
like, what are you gonna do
in those first few seconds to get people
to watch the rest of the video?
If you could have the most
life-changing information,
I mean for, in your video,
but if you don't set the stage right,
people may never get there.
So invest extra energy when
you're writing your outline,
potentially scripting your hook.
- So good Sean, thank you
for those five points.
And I think one of the things
that I've learned from you
is that it's okay to mess up.
As you're going through
and making these videos
and you're doing these
scripts that it's okay
to not always have it perfect, right?
But then there is that point where,
when you're producing the video,
that you can bring your personality to it,
but making sure that you're
hitting these key five things
is something that has massively changed
my brand and what I've been able to do.
So, if you like this type of
content, we are here for you.
We are creating content just like this
and I wanna know in the comment section
do you script your videos?
Let us know, and what type
of videos do you wanna see
here on "The Think Marketing Show?"
Thanks for checkin' out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value
and if you haven't already,
subscribe here to "The
Think Marketing Show"
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcasts.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content
creators, we encourage you
to share it with a friend.
And we'll see you in the next episode.
(upbeat music)